bastión demócrata hasta 2012 ahora del
lado republicano en Florida ganó Este
martes la reelección para gobernador
ronda santis quien quiere ser candidato
a la presidencia y sería el principal
contendor de Donald Trump si este se
lanza a la carrera de la Casa Blanca en
[Aplausos]
ahora este gran éxito estadounidenses
para aquellas personas Florida para
tantos de ellos ha servido como la
tierra prometida nosotros
Nosotros hemos aceptado la libertad
hemos mantenido la ley y el orden hemos
protegido los derechos de los padres
hemos respetado a nuestros
contribuyentes y rechazamos la ideología
progresista
también gana por tercera vez marco Rubio
el candidato republicano al senado lo
más importante es que no solo Vamos a
elegir senadores republicanos vamos a
elegir gente nueva que sabe por qué se
presenta se presentan para salvar a
Estados Unidos se presentan para luchar
por los trabajadores de este país
Florida es uno de los estados péndulo
pasó a ser demócrata en las elecciones
de 2012 cuando guaracobama se llevó a
las presidenciales pero cuando hillary
Clinton se lanzó cuatro años después
perdió por 100.000 votos contra Trump la
historia de la importancia de Florida no
es nueva en el año 2000 el entonces
candidato demócrata al gore quien se
enfrentaba contra George Bush iba
ganando en los conteos perdió en el
estado por menos de 2.000 votos el
republicanos y alzó con la victoria de
las elecciones tras un sonado caso
llevado a la Corte Suprema que invalidó
los resultados en Florida el voto latino
es decisivo los cubanos en su mayoría
republicanos representan el 51% de los
votos y ponen un peso en las elecciones
de medio térmi cuando hacen llegar a
Rubio al senado y a veces a la
gobernación en el 2018